hey what's up guys my name is a channel
welcome to episode 75 of game
programming so so we're finally getting
back to this I'm in Germany right now so
my setup is a little bit different than
it is at home in fátima I'm on my laptop
right now so the screen resolution is
lower even though I guess your video
will still be scale to 1920 by 1080 and
also it's a little slower so if you guys
see an FPS drop and that's just a
different that's just different hardware
okay so don't worry I didn't change
anything okay so what we're gonna do and
what we actually did last time was umm I
remember I think we had collision for
the Gentiles right let's open up our
game and say what we got here doctor
that I am recording good I am okay so
what we had over here was King sure know
here in all his glory and I think I
might actually change his sprite in the
future to make it um well match the
setting a bit more first of all it looks
like I don't know it looks really weird
and also um scale him down a bit so that
his the same size as one tile perhaps or
something like that maybe like a bit
more mid one and a half times it just
seems too big for the world I mean yeah
okay
so yeah I guess we did um I guess we did
this last time so the thing that I
wanted to do now is essentially
particles right so if we click and our
sprite here or our player here he shoots
when the particle sorry when the
projectile hits a wall it just
disappears and that's cool but I think
it'd be even cooler if instead of just
disappearing it would actually pretty
much explored into like an array of
particles I think that'd be really cool
and I think it's a useful thing to teach
you guys as well so I'm just gonna go
ahead and do it so to do that I didn't
want to rush into what I just wanted to
pretty much split it into two episodes
the first episode which is this one will
cover something that I wanted to do long
ago but didn't and that is a bit of
screen class maintenance and the second
half of this episode is going to be
about an essential particle class right
so what a particle class entails and
basically the superclass of all other
subclasses which will be the actual
particles
right so basically laying the template
laying the foundation for particles so
that's what's gonna happen today
mmm my voice might be a little bit off
I'm kind of sick but I am getting but
I'm pretty much better now so I thought
I'd go ahead and make video so screen
cloth now the deal with this is that um
we've got a bunch of render methods here
we will run a tile we've got render
projectile and we've got a render player
yeah what we what we haven't gone
through and we haven't explained is I
might have explained in sedima a half a
year ago how to actually work
essentially why why they do what they do
and how we can how we can control the
size of the accelerators being rendered
right so what I want to do here and
actually probably when do that is the
first render method is a right on the
clear I'm just gonna make a new method
called public void render sprite yeah
and all this is going to be responsible
for is just rendering a single sprite
that's it it's just gonna render a
sprite and doesn't matter what the size
of the sprite is doesn't matter what
color it is it's gonna render a sprite
that's all and that'll be really awesome
as you will see in a minute so
x-position y-position
and these bright that we want to render
and that's what we need yeah okay so
first of all as sorry excuse me as per
usual we need to render win and we
actually need to set our offsets yeah so
last time on last time but in every
other render method you say that we
actually set our offset here by saying X
P minus a equals x offset and what YP
minus equals y offset we didn't do these
s same thing here and what that does in
case you guys don't know is it just
basically offsets our our rendering
toward things so essentially what
happens is we render the sprite to the
portion of the map that we see currently
so in other words if we want to render
our sprite at a particular math
coordinate we obviously move the map
around that's when our player moves the
plate doesn't really move the map moves
and so if we want something to be kind
of glued to the map it's kind of like if
you don't like visual effects or any
kind of video I guess compositing it's
kind of like motion tracking footage
right
we did it we need a glue our our
composite
object here which in this case for
example could be a tile yeah we need it
we need to make sure that it actually
sticks to our our land right so that
when we move our map the sprite moves
with the map so to do that we just have
to subtract his position from the
suitable offsets and remember these
offsets actually get set if we go down
here offsets get set by the set offset
method if we right-click on that hit
references and hit workspace it'll
actually search all um references to
that you can see that here in level in
the level class down here there's a
random method which apparently calls
this thing so if we don't click on that
we can say the screen will set off sigh
gets cold here so what does it happen
every time we render our level we need
to render the offset of the view yeah so
if that makes sense I'm glad because it
only makes off sense to me right now
explaining it but yeah basically it just
sets the offsets for the map so that our
so that whatever we render onto the map
moves moves along with the map ok so now
that we've done that because remember
our sprites that we can what we want to
render these sprites aren't going to
float on the screen this is a big one as
well this render sprite method in fact I
might even add a boolean here called
fixed and fixed it's kind of like if if
the position is fixed so if the position
is fixed if we want to have it on fixed
position and I'll show you guys the
difference as well then we'll do this if
not then we weren't ok and you'll see
the difference here so what else we want
to do we want to actually render the
sprite so we want to take the pixel
array that we have from sprite from our
sprite that we specify and we want to
kind of convert that into we want not
really convert it we just want to set
its value equal to the corresponding
indexes of our displays array so that
makes like no sense but what I'm saying
is we've got an array here called pixels
and that is what we actually see on our
screen so we want to take the entire
sprite and we want to put it into a
specific location on our pixels array
because remember pixels are eight
literally contains the pixels that we
see on our screen when we launch the
game so the pixels in this game window
are dictated their colors are all
dictated and their positions are
dictated by this one pixels array right
so whatever we do whatever we do to that
pixels are right we do to will actually
say the visual result of that right so
whatever we do their pistols array will
be reflected on the screen so what we
want to do is we want to take a button
that pixels arraign instead of setting
its color equal to a specific or a tile
if we put a sprite on top of that we
want to set the colors of those pixels
equal to the cause of the surprise so
that we see the sprite okay so we can do
that by simply just copying and pasting
essentially we're not copying and
pasting we're just assigning particular
values of that pixel array to our sprite
so to do that we need to go through
every single pixel of that sprite and
apply it to the other thing so for y
equals zero as long as Y is less than
our sprite dot width and what is this
okay so apparently contents this is
honestl what that is annoying
what I'm gonna have to check that again
different buta but we've got a um okay
we don't but we will omit so sighs right
okay what we do and it's public I
believe you back a cool so we've um
we've only allowed sprites to be square
now let's just change that so public
sprite and width and height and let's
just say in color yeah so we can make a
rectangle if we want so I'll make um
private int width and height as well
here and if I scroll down here I'll set
this top width equal to width this dot
height equal to height and it's gonna
give us an error because we want to
specify the final modify we'll just put
size equal to I'm with in the cases and
the rectum because we won't have to use
it anyway if I could put it equal to
zero because we shouldn't be using it or
even negative one okay and I think we
can
how do we do it for the other one we
just set the color okay cool so set
color to color okay cool and then we
need it we need a way to actually get
this with an height so over here public
and get with returned with yeah in
public and get high and that will return
hi okay so go get us inside us now but
another reason we do this is a big
question that I get asked and I might do
a um a video well where I just answer
with the comic questions so why make
this private right
we made this private fry with private
height but for some reason we've now
made a public end called get with you
know why don't we just keep this public
and then just reference it but by
calling in sprite dot width
why do we have to call sprite I'll get
with now the reason we do that the
primary reason reason we do that is
because once we create a sprite by
calling a constructor here we don't want
to be able to change its size yeah so by
making this private the only way we can
actually access the value of the sprites
with the height is by calling get with
and you obviously can't use get with to
assign alright so to give you an example
that we in the past we could if we
didn't keep that private we could call
sprite don't width for example we're
sprite is any kind of spray yeah any
kind of instances right of course by
dealt with right that's how we can set
the width yeah by calling that but what
we can also do with this is we can
actually set it equal to anything that's
correct right can do that now if it's
private we we are forced to call sprite
don't get with now you cannot do this
can you that's can't do that okay so
that's the difference that's why we do
that because if we try and call sprite
dot width it's gonna tell us that it's
not visible which is what we want so
hopefully that explained why we use
getters and it's K so these are called
getters essentially okay cool
so sizes negative one and okay one other
thing we should do here is because we've
set size equal to that we should because
we've created two new variables width
and height we should set this top width
equal to size and this too high
sighs okay just to fix that and we'll do
the same for over here just to UM
make sure everything works correctly
okay awesome so what we can do now is
call sprite dog get height Y plus plus
back in our screen class and finally we
X here do do the same thing for the
horizontal sprite get with X yeah now
what we're doing here is we're cycling
through every single pixel of our sprite
object and what we need to do here
basically is just set pixels at that
particular location right now we're
doing without an offset we will do it
and it was an offset in a minute but
pixels X plus y times whatever the width
is which is just width in this case
equals to sprite dot pixels and again
there's no freaking um auto-completion
for some reason but i'll fix after nice
episode x plus y times bright dot get
with ya and that will just work now the
problem here is and this will work if
feathers will never fail it I think the
problem with this is that we'll just
draw it in the top-left corner right
because we're starting from 0 and we're
going all the way to spot don't get hard
and get with so it'll draw it in the top
left corner now we why not we don't want
to do we want to draw them we want to
actually draw the sprite at these
coordinates so to do that we can do what
we've always done and just create a
variable called X a for reason F for the
X and just say that X a is equal to X
right which is our current pixel and
then we need to offset it by something
so X P and then we do something for Y
which we can actually do over here to
prevent you know creating a lot of
variables since this will only happen
for you for values of Y if we put it
into X as well it'll created every time
at grass and X and we don't need that so
Y plus YP and then we need a set we're
gonna make wouldn't a clip it so if X a
is less than 0 or X a is greater than
ankle to width so in other words if we
save deep down of our screen we don't
want to draw
at all that's what we need to specify
all right continue which will just skip
this iteration of the loop and go to the
next one without drawing pixels and if
it's good then yeah we'll just do that
now you don't set this equal to X a ly a
right because we're only accessing what
we just need to access the entirety of
the pixels array for sprite yeah
whereas on the map when you draw it at a
particular location you know sprites
pixels we tend to get them from pixel 1
to pixel from pixel 0 sorry to all the
way to get high and get with okay sweet
so that seems to work well we haven't
tested it yet but it will work that's
really cool so that is going to be the
basis of our particles beliving amount
now let's test it and I think we yeah
we're like 14 minutes holy crap that
took all hell okay we're definitely not
gonna get onto the basis of the particle
class we'll do the next episode but um
this is really important and the reason
is we're gonna use this to draw
particles first of all and second of all
this will allow us to draw any kind of
sprite onto the screen so yes let's
let's try it so over here while we ran
for our player and again this can be
done anywhere but just because render
player conveniently has a in fact let's
um let's not draw it wasn't all doing it
since we can do anyway let's just do it
in our main class and I believe this has
access to render doesn't well screen
yeah it does look a call okay so after
we render everything just before we
actually set the pixel vehicle to do
what they need to be
let's call screen don't render sprite
and I believe we let's just let's do it
at zero zero and the actual sprite let's
just make a new sprite here so sprite
sprite equals new sprite and we'll make
it like 80 pixels by 80 pixels and the
color is that it um let me just say what
our parameters are cuz there's an order
completion which means that I'm
basically programming with it without an
ID here which is annoying where's s
broadcloth
here it is okay I'm so close it um yeah
okay that's it and with it hot I mean
color so eighty eighty and color we'll
just set to our favorite pink color
because that's how we roll okay so
sprite and if it's fixed let's just head
it to false just speaking it see what I
mean
so for the last parameter remember if
it's false then itches ignores its
offsetting so if we launch our game
right now what we should say is a what
crash first a little weird
Nonpoint exception okay we've got to do
one thing here and that is created pixel
array so pixels equals new int width
times height wonderful call on to that
okay so yeah now we see a it will stop
the pink first of all on the reason it's
not pink is because I think we draw it
at all if it's not on its on particular
color
okay so let's ignore the stuff running
background my wife's just recording my
voice because I don't have two monitors
obviously on my laptop so I have to keep
everything on one monitor okay cool so
um let's just okay it doesn't wanna go
wife all right okay sorry about that
let's get back to game mmm okie dokie so
I think that's happened I think it's
rendering in black because um let's just
try oh that's still don't huh that's bad
okay maybe it's some no it's not but
what you can see here is that we should
probably fix this shouldn't we which
fixes but I'm running out of time I
can't let's just try something radically
different okay cool so it's not only
working but what you can see is that if
you actually look really closely you can
see that there's one blue pixel there
and that tells me something that tells
me that something's wrong and the thing
well obviously something wrong but if we
go to sprite class we can say that um
what we have what actually happens is as
we create assess prior width width and
height we set the color equal to
now what happens here is it goes from
size times size that's him that's how
many times it
that's the pixels that is has color too
now if we look at size 4 here we
actually said 2 negative 1 so what is
doing is this going what's negative 1
times negative 1 it's equal to 1 so eyes
less than 1 so for once it actually sets
deep it's legal to color now we don't
want it to do that what we wanted to do
is do it for width times height so we
could change this to width times height
and you can see that it works so now
that we've done this one thing that
we've actually enabled us ourselves to
do that we couldn't do before is sprites
that are not uniform so something like
this and that's really cool now you guys
might be like why would I want this and
you do want this and the reason you want
this is because you can do some cool
things with it like like well for
example let's just add a sprite that's
let's just I don't know maybe like 20
and height okay maybe the water so 40
and what we can do here is we actually
set width minus 40 and look at that
we're starting to look like we've got a
bit of a realm of the mad God kind of
interface so a TD that's probably too
wide and so what you can see here is
that we've actually um enable that
enabled ourselves to grow graphics to
the screen they move along with the
don't move so that stay put onto our
screen as if they're floating above the
entire world like you can see yeah now
clearly this isn't 100% optimized right
now because it is still trying to trying
to compute the data that's behind this
and with the things that layer but for
now you can see why we would want that
now if we set this equal to true what is
actually gonna do is it's gonna put this
somewhere in the space now I'm not sure
where that location is so let's just go
ahead and see if we can find it should
be somewhere in the top left okay here
it is so yeah cuz they over here that
this little pill that was a pillow that
we've created here is um is actually
glued to our mouth yeah what
she's awesome it looks really cool
because it looks like it's part of the
map so that's awesome that's how that
works
okay and that's what we can use it for
so for in the case of our particles what
we could do is something like this so we
can make it probably maybe about three
by three pixels which is this bigger
probably bit to be maybe two by two yeah
that looks good
okay so um and let's just have this
equal to like fifty say yeah here it is
and what you can do is I just so you
guys can see it clear I want to make it
weiss subscribe over here are a little
particle here let's go to the map what I
could do here is you know let's just
render like I don't know
I can see art let's just render on to
them yeah so coming over 100 of them a
hundred of them
I haven't spoken English in a while by
the Y so luckily i'm still remember okay
so let's just set do we have a random
thing yeah I don't think we do
no we aren't I can't that's alright in
fact just for this it's not gonna matter
yes it is I get random random equals in
you random hold that okay
so random next and let's just give it a
variation of maybe about maybe like 10
okay so something kind of like that no
it's ridiculous I know but all we can do
with this is we can essentially have as
you can see multiple particle system
revenue screening sarahfey has basically
hasn't dropped either which is awesome
but yeah that's what we can do we can
just rent a random amount of particles
to the screen and we can animate them as
well so that's how that's going to work
so I hope you enjoyed this episode of
game programming and this is the basics
the basis for our particles and how old
on render them so yeah anyway if you did
place it a like button and I'll see you
guys very very soon with so 76 where we
actually make particles so you guys
you